Gretchen dooshka searches for traces of
protest both past and present in the
late 1960s she attended all the
demonstrations she'd come to West
Germany as an American exchange student
he or she fell in love with and married
student leader Rudi Dutschke
his was the voice of protest revolution
is a long complicated process in which
people must change that's what he aimed
to do back then change himself and the
world people should live in love freely
in peace and solidarity outside Berlin's
Technical University Gretchen encounter
signs of today's protests Marilyn higher
wages for rent and champagne okay
times have changed these days student
protest is more about money than
politics how did you manage to get
twenty thousand people out on the
streets we can't do that it wasn't like
that at first there were other factors
too the Vietnam War played a major role
fifty years ago she and her fellow
students fought for big ideas the 1968
student movement made politics popular
people wanted to get involved now they
find politics useless
my hot up people were absolutely sure
that they were on the right side of
history and that they could achieve
something that we could achieve
something
Wolfgang violent was one of those people
in 1967 as a first year law student he
went to demonstrate in front of the
Deutsche oper
in Berlin the Shah of Iran was here on a
state visit students came to protest
against the dictator and his regime
police used brutal tactics to control
the crowd fatally shooting student Benno
ona's org
everyone felt that what happened to be
known as org could have happened to them
they beat us without cause it wasn't
just the shots a kind of massacre took
place here Germany's press also joined
in the battle against the demonstrators
oXXO Springer's bill tabloid in
particular 10 months later shots rang
out again this man gunned down student
leader Rudi Dutschke calling him a dirty
communist Pig dooshka survived severely
injured when the built newspaper turned
on someone people believed it and they
let themselves get stirred up protests
escalated in front of the axel springer
building in 1968 the German government
passed emergency acts which allowed
basic rights to be curbed just two
decades after the Nazi dictatorship
ended students were shocked by these
laws the flood young we were afraid that
this short phase of democracy in West
Germany would end again for bias but
then came 1969 and Vili beyond the first
social democratic Chancellor of the
Federal Republic of Germany
a Cultural Revolution took place slowly
but inexorably whether it was raising
children the working world or even love
things became more open more liberal
afterwards it was a different state than
it had been before in 1979 Gretchen
Duchess husband Rudy died from the
after-effects of the brain damage caused
by the assassination attempt today
Gretchen dooshka lives in a feminist
housing project in Berlin as a member of
the Green Party she continues to fight
for a better world to this day I think
the environment is our most pressing
problem reinstated because without the
world we have nothing
wolf Convy lon chose to try to change
the system from within in 1978 he helped
found Berlin's Green Party later he even
became Berlin's justice senator official
car and tie included but he still
attends demonstrations against
right-wing extremism in Germany populist
SAR gaining ground during the last
parliamentary elections the far-right
AFD party received 12% of the vote in a
sense the AFD protests against the
weakest members of society they do it
with populist themes with racism
exclusion and kicking people when
they're down our protest was always
against the higher-ups there 12% and
we're what 88% and they can't take that
away from us in front of the Axel
Springer Building home to the bill
tabloid there's now a Rudi Dutschke
street the student protesters of old are
now an integral part of the society they
once fought against then changed
they now defend it against attacks from
the far-right their battle continues
you